there is a pretty significant concern
about the national security implications
of the solomon islands selling some
uh particularly resource rich
and facilities uh uh
you know port facility capabilities to
chinese interests the these are
unsettling on a number of levels uh
there is concern that the sogovari
government in the solomon islands has
been effectively co-opted by china
because of the gs
significance of the solomon islands
these islands that were effectively if
occupied and controlled by an enemy
would be able to isolate australia from
north america
one would be naive to think that china
isn't looking through a strategic prism
when it engages with kiribati
solomon islands tonga fiji and elsewhere
there is considerable unease in
australia about what's happening
there is an overwhelming
spike in the level of concern about
china's
adversarial ambitions
and its intentions
they have been reinforced by
the show of force in and around taiwan
following nancy pelosi's visit
that has
resonated in australia in a way that
perhaps president xi may not have quite
appreciated
because it has generated a
not so much a fear and a desire to you
know applicate but a sense of oh this
means we really do need to double down
on
bolstering our own ability to defend
ourselves and to stand up for what we
believe in
the shift in mood in australia is
largely i would contend a response to
china's actions
after the tribe arbitral tribunal ruling
the wolf wire diplomacy the political
interference the cyber attacks and then
of course the the the icing on the cake
was the the covered response the
australia is closely watching reactions
in the united states how the united
states responds from here on is
something of acute attention in
australia there is a fine balance if you
like between our fear of abandonment
coupled with a fear of entrapment the
fear that perhaps an overly you know
assertive united states could actually
contribute to an escalation over taiwan
that would uh like a sucking vortex
drawing australia as a close and trusted
ally into a fight that australia uh
would very much like to avoid but might
feel compelled to support the united
states over there is a nervousness in
australia
that the united states perhaps doesn't
have the ticker
to pursue this economically and will be
focused more instead militarily an
approach that
as we've seen you know the united states
has not win won that many wars in the
last few decades and there's a
nervousness that
there is a kind of default to military
action
we've got a trillion dollar hammer if
you like arguably looking for a nail
and china has been assiduously avoiding
presenting a nail